[Music]
[Music]
hello i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now today we'll be
joined from london by david rooney who
will be talking about his book about
time a history of civilization in 12
clocks i first met david over two
decades ago when he was a curator at the
science museum and we were installing
the very first prototype of the ten
thousand year clock there since that
time he's been a curator at the
greenwich time museum and back at the
science museum overseeing much larger
collections but most recently doing
research for this book in the way that
clocks and civilization have interacted
for millennia welcome david rooney
thanks alexander and i'm really glad to
have this opportunity to thank everyone
involved with along now past and present
because when i first encountered you
alexander and the prototype clock of the
long now 21 years ago
i really had no idea just how much and
in so many different ways
the work of the foundation would
influence the way that i think not just
about clocks and technology
but about civilizations
and all the conversations i've had with
you since the year 2000 have just kept
building for me the idea that clocks
play a unique role in civilizations they
can illuminate our past and our futures
in powerful ways
but not just illuminate our
civilizational stories i've come to see
how much clocks have been deeply rooted
actors in those stories
to see the clocks are now and always
have been at the heart of everything we
care about as humans
what's come to fascinate me most is what
clocks mean a question that's answered
by looking at why people have made them
who's really sitting behind their faces
and the more i've learned the more it's
become obvious that the technical
history of horology is only the start of
the story it's human motivation and how
the world works that really interests me
which i guess helps explain why i
started seeing time as a story centered
on power control
money morality and belief
and in my book which covers far more
than i'll have time to touch on today
and covers what i will talk about today
in much greater detail
and look at how we can all understand
our history and future better
if we examine clocks as artifacts that
shed light on aspects of civilizations
that matter to us
big themes
the ways we're governed the beliefs we
hold the ways we tell stories
we can use the history of clocks to look
at capitalism
at the exchange of knowledge the
building of empires and the radical
changes to our lives brought by
industrialization
clocks mediate our sense of morality our
sense of right and wrong and they help
us construct our identities our sense of
who we are and with clocks i think we'll
have to look unflinchingly at life
death
war and peace
but to do that i also think we benefit
from expanding our definition of what
the word clock means
of course understanding clock technology
is crucial in these big stories and
different technologies enable different
civilization level outcomes
but using the word clock to mean the
geared mechanical devices invented in
europe in the 13th century and all the
similar devices we've made since is
limiting
i wanted to zoom right out so that we
might spot bigger and longer patterns
through history and across geography and
civilizations
so i use the word clock to mean any
human-made device with the purpose of
tracking the passage of time that
includes sundials hourglasses water
clocks
crowing roosters time finding telescopes
time signals wrist watches whatever
because to say that big powerful
mechanical clocks were invented in
europe in the 13th century hides the
fact for instance
that big powerful mechanical clocks were
constructed by islamic makers long
before that they were water clocks not
weight driven geared clocks but they
were no less significant in shaping our
world
and in the modern age to think of clocks
as devices we can easily see in our
everyday lives occludes the countless
devices hidden from view the most gps
satellites or high security data centers
are just two locations where clocks live
and where timing has transformed
and been transformed by the modern world
but among all that i think there's a
thread that unites pretty much all the
stories that i cover in the book and
it's a thread that has two ends one end
people have always used clocks to
control us and keep us in order but at
the other end
people have also always resisted the
power clocks have over us or rather
resisted the people that clocks have
been proxies for
and i certainly hope a long now audience
would be sympathetic to the idea that
while clocks might oppress us
clocks can and will save us as well
so in exploring that wider story of
control and resistance i'm going to
focus today on three clocks
the clock at greenwich is an early
electric clock set in the middle of a
park
the mumbai clock is set in a tower in
the city centre
and the edinburgh clock didn't tell the
time at all it was used to drive a
telescope but all three clocks had one
thing in common
there were sites of resistance
there were targets of violent attack
because of what or rather who they stood
for
the story behind the greenwich episode
began far away from london
the last two decades of the 19th century
saw a series of anarchist-inspired
terrorist attacks hit countries across
europe
in november 1884 an international
diplomatic conference was held at
washington d.c
that selected greenwich's world famous
observatory as the prime meridian of the
world the origin for all time and space
measurement the place whose time would
set the beat for the whole world
now the reason given for selecting
greenwich was a practical one
something like 75 percent of the world's
ships by tonnage used charts based on
the greenwich meridian and that was
because the london chart makers were the
most prolific
so selecting the greenwich meridian was
seen to inconvenience the fewest people
the only major country attending the
washington conference to abstain from
the vote for greenwich
was france
and the conference opened what was to
become a running saw in the psyche of
the french nation
at the time the french delegate lobbied
hard for the decision to be reversed
and later france just refused to
recognize the results of the conference
french commentators saw it as an act of
hostile imperialism on the part of
britain and i think it's easy to see
their point
although you might well disagree
in january 1885 just a few weeks after
the washington meridian conference shown
a spotlight on his observatory the
astronomer royale at greenwich william
christie wrote to his government worried
about possible bomb attacks on his
buildings
just three weeks later an anonymous
letter was received by the authorities
containing threats to blow up saint
paul's cathedral prompting them to close
off the cathedral's clock and bell
chamber fearing a symbolic act of
violence against the clock and it
remained closed for years
by late 1893 anarchist terrorists were
particularly active in france
culminating in a bombing of the chamber
of deputies in paris that december
then on the evening of monday the 12th
of february 1894
an anarchist threw a bomb into the
crowded cafe of the grand hotel terminu
in the rue san lazar in paris next to a
major railway station 20 people were
injured in the explosion and one of them
later died from his injuries
three days later
in england an explosion was heard across
greenwich the royal observatory gate
porter and two of its astronomers raced
out towards a path where they could see
smoke rising
there they found the park keeper and two
pupils from a local boys school who'd
been first on the scene
first sight that didn't appear to be
much wrong a young man later identified
as marshall bordan was kneeling on the
path by railings perfectly still
with his head bowed
but then he fell forward
he was taken to a nearby hospital
where he died 25 minutes later
marshall bourdain was a french anarchist
and he knew emil henry the person who'd
attacked the grand hotel in paris three
days earlier very well
marshall bourdain had been carrying a
bomb to the greenwich observatory he was
only meters away from his target with
the bomb primed in his hand when he
tripped and fell forward onto it it
exploded and killed him
just around the corner from where he was
fatally injured are the gates that lead
into the observatory's large courtyard
and there beside the gates to this day
is the large round white dial of the
observatory's electric public clock
set in a wall at head height behind
glass
it's an official clock that had
displayed britain's standardized
authoritative
greenwich meantime
since the mid-19th century
in 1884 when the western world's
government representatives had decided
that all the people of earth should
march to the beat of one clock
it was this clock it was the powerful
living embodiment of all that anarchists
like burden despised authority and
hierarchy
this was to have been the end of
marshall bourdain's journey that day in
1894 if he hadn't tripped and bungled
the plan
marshall bordan had been moments away
from bombing greenwich meantime itself
emile henry the paris bomber said this
at his trial
he said
you have hanged us in chicago
decapitated us in germany garrodded us
in her wreth
shot us in barcelona guillotined us in
monbriza and in paris but what you can
never destroy is anarchy
its roots are too deep born in a
poisonous society which is falling apart
anarchism he said
is a violent reaction against the
established order
and ori's choice of words there is
telling established order means
political institutions and structures
but it also refers to the work of
measurement scientists like the
astronomers working at time-finding
observatories
their work is in establishing order
then as now it was impossible to
separate science from society impossible
to see the work of any institution like
an observatory as purely scientific
rather than bound up in politics and
wider culture
the greenwich observatory clock is an
imperial clock
and clocks and empires go hand in hand
in 1615 walter raleigh had said
whosoever commands the sea commands the
trade
whosoever commands the trade of the
world commands the riches of the world
and consequently the world
itself the story of longitude so deftly
told by davis sobel and others is now
widely known
accurate timekeeping on board the ships
of maritime empires enabled safe and
accurate navigation
that meant portable precision
timekeepers or chronometers carried on
board ships
providing a fixed time reference from
which east-west positions could be
calculated backed up by the lunar
distance method of timekeeping which
used the moon and stars like the hands
of a giant celestial clock
both temporal technologies had been
developed in the 18th century and by
about 1810 had become widespread
that story is now famous partly because
it's pretty heroic
but a story that's less often remarked
on is the vast infrastructure of timing
that had to be built across the globe in
order to measure and then distribute the
precise time that sailors needed in
order to set their chronometers right
during long voyages
but i think infrastructure is pretty
important too which is why i spend so
much time studying it and exploring it
the time ball set up at the greenwich
observatory in 1833
to transmit time to sailors waiting in
the river thames below is fairly well
known
but the same year
out of sight of the british imperial
capital
another time bowl was erected by the
british government that one was on the
coast of southern africa at the cape of
good hope
before too long it was joined by
literally hundreds of time signaling
structures
acting as frontier foot soldiers around
the coastlines of all empires
and let me be clear about the scale of
this infrastructure of time
in 1908 the british navy carried out a
survey that listed a total of 200 time
signals
that could be found on coastlines or in
ports around the world
there are usually time balls like the
one at greenwich or built for a very
different reason the one in new york's
times square
but sometimes they took the form of
timed disks or time guns or time
signaling flags
200 of them and the document reveals the
astonishing geographical reach of the
world's maritime powers
it was by far the world's biggest
network of time signaling stations
but by 1908 the year the survey was
published america was fast catching up
as a world power having built 22 coastal
time signals on its own soil with a
further two in its porch possessions in
the philippines each and every one of
these time signal installations was a
major undertaking involving complex
surveying
engineering land acquisition the
recruitment and management of labor
forces
legal negotiation maintenance
astronomical observation instrument
making
and a huge amount of expertise developed
over decades or centuries
each one was a heavy investment and a
long-term liability and taken together
with the tens of thousands of shipboard
chronometers for which they were built
and the global network of chronometer
testing stations chronometer and
clockmakers retailers supply depots
not to mention the dozens of government
astronomical observatories that found
the time in the first place to
distribute across this network
we can see a vast global physical
presence of time of clocks in one form
or another
that's been all but forgotten
plot all these time signals and
chronometers on a map of the world and
you can see how clocks enabled empires
of course clocks being used to control
populations was hardly a new feature of
civilizations
as far back as we care to look we can
find evidence both of clocks being used
to keep us in order and of people
resisting
we could go back over 2 200 years to see
a good example of this
in the year 263 bce
the first public sundial was installed
in ancient rome
it was set on a tall column at the heart
of the roman forum right at the center
of the city
it's long since been lost but similar
ones have survived including one from
pompeii
it had been captured as war booty from
the city of catania it showed that rome
was on top and the crowd had gone wild
the day it was first revealed by the
sicily war hero
manius valerius maximus
but the people soon changed their mind
because valerius's public sundial set
high atop its triumphal column was just
the first of many installed across the
city
each designed to regulate and control
the daily activities of rome's citizens
and they very quickly became uneasy at
the intrusion of this new timekeeping
technology
rome's playwrights and critics poured
scorn on the new devices
riding just a few years after the first
sundial had been installed one
exasperated playwright made a character
exclaim
the gods confound the man who first
found out how to distinguish ours
confound him too who in this place set
up a sundial to cut and hack my days so
wretchedly into small pieces
the character went on you know when i
was a boy my stomach was the only
sundial
by far the best and truest compared to
all of these it used to warn me to eat
but now what there is isn't eaten unless
the sun says so
finally the character said in fact towns
so stuffed with sundials that most
people crawl along shriveled up with
hunger
doesn't that just sound so modern that
idea that we can't even eat until the
clock allows us the clocks are cutting
and hacking our days into smaller and
smaller pieces and controlling what we
can and cannot do
it sounds like the industrial revolution
it could have been written yesterday a
later writer described rome's sundials
as hateful
and called for the columns on which they
were fixed to be torn down with crowbars
and as well as seeing them like the
factory or office clock telling us when
we can break for a meal
we should also think of these roman
sundials as early clock towers
mounded up high
looking over the people and standing for
rome's ruling classes themselves
in ancient imperial china
towers carrying drums or bells loomed
large over towns and cities often
centered on marketplaces
anybody caught on the streets after the
night bells sounded might be arrested
and beaten
across imperial japan from at least the
8th century onwards each major city had
its water clock or klepsidra and a tall
tower from which time was sounded to the
public clock towers were part of the
ordering infrastructure of cities
we now know about the coastal time bowls
that helped imperial ships navigate
across the oceans
and by this time the coast of africa was
lined with lofty time signals but these
tall towers weren't the only temporal
infrastructure of empire wherever the
colonisers went
clock towers high over the people's
heads accompanied them on their march
in southeastern australia from the 1820s
onwards
british colonizers engaged in an
energetic programme of clock tower
building as they imported western ideas
of discipline and order
but it was in india that the british
clock tower project reached its greatest
and most zealous heights britain's grip
on india tightened hard in the late
1850s after a bloody uprising in 1857
against its rule
building construction formed a crucial
part of this governing program and tall
clock towers with loud bells sounding
the westminster chimes were commissioned
for every major indian town occupied by
the british
and they were impossible to miss
the clock tower built in the 1870s as
part of mayo college a new boarding
school campus at ajmer in today's
rajasthan
intended to be the eaton of india showed
the power of clock towers to represent
the ruling classes by proxy
at nearly 30 meters in height the mayo
college clock loomed over the area
it was visible to anybody approaching
ajmer long before the city itself came
into view and just take a look at it it
was topped by a huge iron crown
just like the one worn by queen victoria
who was proclaimed empress of india in
1877 the year that construction of mayo
college began the clock tower was the
empress commanding over her domain
in total over 100 clock towers were
built in india during the colonial
period not all by british colonialists
but nevertheless an astonishing
construction program but people resist
i told you i wanted to focus on three
clocks today and the first was the
greenwich observatory gaze clock that
was the target of resistance in 1894
while the second clock was in mumbai or
bombay as it was then called
in 1898 four years after the greenwich
bombing the indian city was gripped by
rioting and strikes by the native hindu
and muslim population
resisting repressive public health
measures being carried out by the local
british government
at the geographical
social and strategic heart of the city
dividing the native and european areas
sat the british built crawford market
rising above it overlooking a busy
intersection and facing bombay's police
station was the market's clock tower
on the evening of friday the 11th of
march 1898
as anti-colonial unrest grew across the
city
native indian attackers with rifles
opened fire on the clock destroying one
of its brightly illuminated dials
a long-running dispute about time
standardization in bombay in the 1880s
had meant that public clocks had taken
on a particular symbolic meaning in the
city
remember that this was the decade of the
international meridian conference and
perhaps you thought i was overstating
the case that choosing greenwich time as
the time base for the world was an act
of imperial violence well the british
tried to force a standard time actually
madras time onto bombay
it had been resisted but the argument
was still fresh in the memories of the
bombay population in 1898 when the
crawford margaret clock was attacked
seven years after that in 1905
arguments about standard time in the
city re-emerged
as the british government tried to unify
all of india's population under a single
time zone
five and a half hours ahead of greenwich
at a time of intense political tension
over british colonialism in india
standard time in bombay took on ever
more powerful symbolic meaning
the choice of time kept on the public
clocks across the city bombay time
madras time or the new indian standard
time
was an expression of colonial allegiance
or resistance
in january 1906 the largest textile mill
in bombay changed its clocks to the new
standard time without informing its four
and a half thousand workers
when they turned up that morning to
begin their shifts and discovered what
had happened they immediately went on
strike and began to pelt the mills clock
tower with stones
public clocks in bombay had become
symbols of british domination
the indian people had resisted
it wasn't clocks they were fighting it
was the viceroy
and wherever we find clocks we can see
the exercise of power
the world's largest sundial was built in
the indian city of jaipur
in the 1730s for an ambitious maharaja
sawai jai singh ii it's still the
largest sundial in the world today
it was part of a suite of monumental
astronomical observatories that jai
singh built across india not just to
find the secrets of the heavens but to
consolidate his own rule
and project power
what jai singh had built a jaipur was a
huge edifice taking the form of a great
triangular wall
fashioned out of stone and plaster
aligned perfectly north to south
with its upper surface angled exactly to
the latitude of jaipur so it was
parallel with the earth's axis
it occupied a footprint of 40 by 44
meters dug more than three metres into
the ground and rose 23 meters into the
air
which is quarter of the height of
london's big ben
the construction of which began just
over a century later
there was a long flight of steps running
up the center of the triangular wall
towards its summit which allowed
astronomers including jai singh himself
to make careful observations
and he had the structure topped with a
roofed pavilion in which the observer
could work protected from the hot jaipur
sun
alongside this monumental central angled
gnomon or shadow indicator sat two lower
structures known as quadrants
onto whose curved surfaces the shadow of
the gnomon fell
with finely marked scales divided into
two second intervals
and the whole thing was aligned
perfectly to tolerances of just a few
millimeters
so that it could keep time to within a
couple of seconds
and when it was completed in 1735 it was
impossible to ignore
one mid-18th century visitor described
the sundial as astonishing
and commented that on its summit there
is an observation tower that overlooks
the whole town
and so tall that one cannot be there
without one's head turning
who would you have seen there more often
than not the maharaja himself literally
towering over his people
and he wasn't the first ambitious ruler
embroiled in local power struggles to
build a monumental observatory to
project power over a region
in 1259 in maraga in today's iran the
mongol leader hulugu khan built a huge
observatory the year after he'd sacked
baghdad and ended the islamic golden age
in 15th century samarkand in today's
uzbekistan the timurid ruler uruk beg
built an observatory that became the
most revered in the world
he too had grown up in a world of
conflict
and a family war for dynastic succession
in paris in 1667 louis xiv founded an
observatory that towered over its
surroundings he was just 26 and that
same year he embarked on a punishing
half-century campaign of war against the
other powers of europe
the greenwich observatory of 1675
occupied a similarly lofty position
and its founding came as the king
charles ii
was bankrolling a violent gold and slave
trading empire in africa
another network of time-finding
installations built to project power and
keep populations in order
a global network which like the others
brought many benefits
but which excluded whole sectors of
society
but people resist
i'd like to conclude with the third
clock of the talk
in may 1913 a bomb explosion ripped
through scotland's royal observatory in
edinburgh
a large earthenware jar packed with
gunpowder had been placed in the middle
story of the western telescope dome
next to an iron staircase it was
connected to a 30 foot fuse that had
been run down the staircase to the room
below
which housed the telescope chronograph a
clockwork device for timing observations
the damage caused by the explosion was
extensive windows and doors had been
blown out plaster ceilings were
shattered
some of the staircase was blown off
splinters of glass were recovered 100
feet from the building
the heavy floor of the telescope room
directly above the bomb had been knocked
off the kobolds that supported it and
had been badly damaged
the driving clock which kept the
telescope fixed on a star while the
earth rotated was nearly destroyed
there was little doubt which group had
carried out the bombing that night
although the individuals involved were
never identified or caught
two notes were left at the scene the
first read from the beginning of the
world
every stage of human progress has been
from scaffold to scaffold
and from stake to stake
the other said
how beggarly appears argument before
defiant deed
votes for women
this bombing was the work of
suffragettes and once again this was an
act of resistance against global
structures of power
carried out by those excluded from the
benefits of those structures
for women campaigning for universal
suffrage as with anarchists fighting
against authority and hierarchy and with
people living under violently repressive
colonialists
some clocks
could look like tyrants
in 1944 the canadian writer george
woodcock wrote an essay called the
tyranny of the clock
he said
the clock represents an element of
mechanical tyranny in the lives of
modern men more potent than any
individual exploiter or any other
machine
the idea of clocks as tyrants has stayed
with us ever since because clocks can be
made by tyrants to enact their control
and coercion
in all the myriad ways we've explored
today
but this is a positive message believe
it or not it's a message of hope for the
future
people aren't all bad
clocks have brought great benefits to
humankind across time and civilizations
but as with all power structures
some people benefit more than others
some people have more control than
others
but we can all resist
clocks are tools at our disposal
if other people are using them to
control our lives we can use them
ourselves too to good effect just like
the long nas been doing since the 1990s
and just like people have been doing
through history
let's see clocks for what they are
they're proxies for humans
so let's look behind the faces of our
clocks and see who we're really dealing
with
and if we don't like who we see
let us build different clocks
thank you so much david um and please
excuse my voice but i'd like to welcome
you from uh your place in uh greenwich
uk welcome
it's great to see you zanda hi there
really great to be here right with you
um i think one of the things that's
really interesting that i think comes up
as i hear your talk is you know as as a
clock builder myself of working on this
10 000 year clock i've really found that
that what clocks often are are kind of
mirrors
um and you know what people see in that
clock is is is in some way themselves in
their own culture and it seems that that
came across in your research is that
is that a good description of what you
were finding
i think that's a really important way of
looking at clocks
that um
kind of repeatedly as i was as i was
thinking more and more about about the
role that clocks play and the possibly
unique role that clocks play in
societies
comes down to senses of identity
and in in the sense of
um
they're proxies for for people us us and
other people and that we pour our
identities into clocks
we form relationships with clocks as
with people whether that's on the
national scale
with
national clocks like big ben in london
which stands not just for
british government but british people
um
or
the largest clock in the world is in
mecca
as well it's it's also standing for a
people uh and a whole religion it seems
and it's really interesting the mega
clock which is
six times the size of big ben
it's built overlooking the most holy
sites of islam the great mosque in mecca
and it looks like big ben but it's it's
a it's an islamic um version with a
crescent moon on the top
um
and and when that was completed in 2012
i think
and there was lobbying by some saudi
officials to get the prime meridian of
the world
changed from greenwich to mecca
because these kind of ideas coming
together which is that the clocks kind
of contain our identities but also that
clocks enact power structures um i think
i was finding with two very powerful
ways of looking at them through history
indiana i think it's it's very
interesting you bring up 2012 we have
several people who uh wanted to ask a
little bit about um you know the mayan
clocks and uh you know
they're really calendar systems that we
have found but that you know that
calendar wheel that has
one of the few things that made it
through uh from the mayan culture to our
modern culture has wielded power all the
way up until you know people thought the
world was going to end in 2012 because
of it um so i think it's it's
interesting how powerful some of these
symbols can really be
and one of and what one example of that
um
which which i was astonished to kind of
track through history
the idea of clocks as symbols which
endure
was the symbol of the hourglass or the
sand glass
and i started
in the book i started to track through
where the idea first started that
associated the sunglass or the hourglass
the sand clock
with ideas about virtue about living
well on earth
first with the idea of temperance living
a well ordered
life not to excess
and then became associated as we know
the day with the symbol of time itself
father time
and then with the symbol of death the
end of our time
and that i mean that all started in the
14th century and was playing through
into the 15th and 16th
and it was actually only after i'd
finished the first um draft of the book
and it was with my editor and he said
you have realized haven't you that the
symbol
used by extinction rebellion
and other groups who are thinking about
how to live life better on earth because
otherwise extinction awaits us is an
hourglass on all of the placards and and
banners of
protests around the world it's a
stylized hourglass that symbol has
endured since the since the 14th century
really powerful
indeed yeah and there's many cultures
you know even today that you know giving
someone a clock is actually a negative
thing because you're you're counting
their days effectively uh which i think
is interesting um and we're going to be
bringing in uh after this next question
uh two founding board members both kevin
kelly and stuart brown from long now um
but one story i would love for you to
tell because it was it was a subject of
your last book which i loved so much um
and i think it's a very powerful story
and i'd love for you to kind of say what
you think it means in this context but
it's you know it's the story of how time
was delivered um throughout greenwich um
by um by you know elizabeth belleville
um and and you know her i was her
husband before that and many generations
of people before that but i think it's
it's such a powerful story you know it
goes along with your the way that
time was projected around the globe but
it started with this much more local
thing
and the story of the the belleville
family
when when i started to look into that
story it felt like a small story a small
you know provincial story about
about this family who was selling time
around london to people who wanted
accurate time and it started in the
1830s
before um telegraph time or wireless
time how would you know the time
accurately to a fraction of a second
in the 1830s and the answer was well
either you'd find it yourself with a
really good time finding telescope
which was difficult to do
or if you lived in a city where there
was a local observatory like london has
greenwich you could visit the
observatory and ask for the time and
what john belleville started to do was
to flip that round and to take the time
from the greenwich observatory around
london in a watch and people would pay
um an annual fee for a weekly visit
that was then continued by his wife
after he died maria belleville and then
ruth belleville their daughter elizabeth
ruth belleville carried it on until 1940
so this so here was a really interesting
local story a really interesting story
but but quite small and the more i
thought about what that meant and why
people were still paying good money
through into the 20th century and not
just you know not just a few years after
telegraph time or radio time started but
decades after
made me think a lot about biggest a
bigger theme which is about
trust in technology
and the role of trust in new
technologies how do we come to trust
technologies particularly if they're
important to us for our livelihoods or
for for life at sea
um
and and it helps to reinforce something
else uh which many of the people in the
long now have have
helped me see
which is about
new technologies
never replacing all technologies but
merely adding more layers of complexity
the idea that that when
telegraph time or radio time came along
that they replaced these older methods
they didn't they didn't they just
co-existed
and the technological landscape became
more complex
and and i was very interested therefore
in that in the story of ruse belleville
not as an anachronism
but as somebody who was providing a
valued service that people trusted and
valued right up until the second world
war
and it fed quite a lot of the ideas that
that have come since for me
indeed well i'd like to welcome in uh
kevin kelly and stuart brandt
hello hey greetings
great to have you both great um to uh to
one of you have a question for our david
i have a question um david and that is
um
what do you make of the fact that today
um almost any electronic device is
keeping time
uh and in fact um
gps
or the way that we navigate is actually
just basically running off of timestamps
um so that kind of pervasive way in
which everything is now
keeping time what do you make of that
um that's a great question it's
something that that again kind of built
and built as i was um researching this
um
if if we consider gps
satellites or if we consider global
navigation satellites so including the
the russian system glonass the chinese
system beidou
um
european system galileo coming on stream
there's probably i don't know 100
satellites overhead right now and all
they are is flying clocks
all they are is each one carrying maybe
three or four um super precise atomic
clocks beaming time signals to earth so
that if you're using it for navigation
it trilaterates the position to
you know centimeters now or better
but they've also become the time signal
for the world they've replaced many of
the systems like ruth belleville
of terrestrial time distribution
and so i mean i'm i'm trying to work out
there can't be any of the clocks that
have ever been made in human history
that have been looked at more
than those maybe 300 blocks which are
right over our heads right now
and that pervasiveness
where every infrastructure
in the modern world relies on time
whether that's
telecoms
or power distribution
or financial trading
stock markets you know they all rely on
these time stamps or or temp or
synchronization by clocks
and most of them now rely on these 100
satellites and their military
technologies which are in the control of
basically three major powers
and i find that terrifying
and and one of the reasons and therefore
interesting
of course to study and one of the
reasons why i find it so interesting is
how hidden they are
how you know right up until i don't know
maybe the middle of the 20th century we
knew where our clocks were
and we celebrated them right so so those
clocks that the clocks which kept
stock markets on time from the 17th
century onwards were huge tall looming
clock towers we saw some of them on the
film
people could see them hear them and they
were they were part of our lives
and and then clock started to disappear
and time started to disappear
and and now there are those clocks which
are embedded in data centers thousands
of clocks and data centers which are
running everything from
cloud computing to high frequency
trading
and clocks in satellites clocks
everywhere the ones on our the ones on
our wrists or on our office walls that
they they almost don't matter anymore
it's what clocks do for us now is
astonishing and and it's something which
um interests me greatly and it's it is
interesting that um a lot of the clocks
that you mentioned
were on towers and that gave them some
authority and basically the satellite
ones are just really tall towers
they're so tall and above us
that we can't see them but they're still
towering over us and so there's this
idea of the clocked tower that's sort of
interesting
well i think what's also interesting
about the gps satellite network is when
it was first introduced and made public
they actually they had a they had a
scrambling signal on it because they
were afraid that time could be used as a
weapon effectively which can if it's
used for positioning something like a
missile
and you know after a while there was
algorithm that defeated it but um this
idea of time as a weapon was extremely
present when the gps network was first
was first introduced
let's go ahead and start
uh david you know it was great to see
you back when we installed the long now
first iteration along now clock the
science museum
uh and i just now finished your
extremely wonderful book um i was going
to ask about gps being the
sort of modern version of all those uh
ball dropping clocks all over the world
of the sort of globalization
synchronization techniques and longitude
and so on
um but you're very kind that you end
your book with um
some sense of of what our clock
means to you the the long now clock that
we're building in texas
uh the one that we installed there at
the science museum that you were
responsible for winding up
uh what does long mouse clock mean to
you because it's not about
synchronization like all these other
things
um
i mean it's been 21 years now
and
and when i said it was at the start of
the film that that that meeting you and
and being involved peripherally with
that clock
at that from from at that formative time
of my
life and career
um has has absolutely guided my way of
thinking
throughout
and and and
what what what the clock and the clock
concept has done is
is manifold
um
the idea of
well the idea of looking longer and
seeing everything right now better um is
a very powerful
message which is
catalyzed by the clock
um
and the idea that i mentioned that i
talked about in in the film about
resistance about how
it's very easy to get i think fatalistic
about the role that clocks have played
in civilizations that they oppress us
other people oppress us and they have
power over us which we cannot resist
um
i feel very uncomfortable with and what
the long now clock has helped me see
is that clocks clocks can be used as
tools to resist
that control as well as well as clocks
being targets for resistance
so i said at the end you know if if we
don't like what clocks do the more we
find out about them and i think we
should find out more ab about them
then let's make different clocks
you know
clocks are human-made constructs
we can choose to make different ones as
you did
well it occurs to me that um
yeah lots of clocks are about
synchronization this one is not
lots of clocks are about reliability
um
and this one definitely is about
reliability in the sense that alexander
and danny designed it and built it to be
reliably keeping time for at minimum as
you point out in the book 10 000 years
hopefully two or three times that
eventually
and um
it you know we were tempted to do some
kind of calendar or things like that and
certainly astronomically based and it
has the array of planets and whatnot in
the middle but somehow the the fact that
there's a tick
that you
hear and then another one and another
one they're slow
in the ten thousand year clock with
their they're in your face
and um
and also size like big ben or like the
the one in mecca
uh that it is you know hundreds of feet
tall inside a mountain
monumentality seems to be part of what
it's about
what's your sense of how these various
elements
are part of what we understand in terms
of the instruments that represent time
to us
i think um
i'm not sure what i think about that i
think i think the idea of um
there's something about the idea of
clocks being proxies for for us
involves them being alive
which this might sound glib but the idea
of clocks having heartbeats
absolutely low or fast
helps us see them as um as
as one of us
which calendars
don't have
um so the tick of the clock even the
slow tick of the clock makes it human
um and we care about humans
and then the money mentality
um
extends extends that in the
in the vertical axis
you know so when i was talking about
clock towers being the empress of india
or people commanding over us
um
um
what you've made is a is a clock which
has the same presence but plays a
different role
and what i always find kind of amazing
is
as we were researching things like the
the pendulum and the escapement in the
club for
for this clock ten thousand year clock
um and then you look at something like a
rolex and how many times it ticks
usually before you know in 20 years or
so between service intervals and then
you look at you know animal hearts or
human hearts they all kind of have the
same number of ticks in them in terms of
the order of magnitude of number of
times these things tick and
and so there is this very kind of human
um or natural cycle that even makes its
way into these very mechanical systems
um at least the ones that are engineered
well certainly um you know the entire
clock team that's been building um
especially the escapement that i'm just
a small part of that team the the
escapement and the and the pendulum work
is some of the some of the most detailed
work that that i've ever even witnessed
to be a part of and and watching you
know i believe that we were doing some
tests on our pendulum just the other
week we actually could see that the
earthquake in haiti from l.a
in the data
so it's a you know it's that's how
that's how kind of sensitive some of
these systems are and it's uh it's
pretty amazing to watch watch them be
built and they but they start to take on
this notion of a very organic nature
which is very cool
stewart
i've got a question that danny messaged
to me he said danny hillis writes
unlike the clocks that david you
described
the 10 000
uh your clock is deep in the ground away
from people so it's monumental but it's
not like something you look up to
um
the opposite of a city tower are there
other clocks like that that are sort of
buried away
uh occurred to me maybe the one in osaka
has that quality
i think that's right um the the
the um time capsule buried um in japan
in 1970
um
containing you know
all the kind of the all of the the
curated collections of civilization at
that time
not to be dug up for 5000 years and it
includes um a plutonium clock
um which uses um plutonium decay of
beta particles into a gas chamber which
expands like an accordion's bellows and
as it expands it pulls the hand around
the
the dial of the clock um
each each um division on the dial is 100
years so so that is buried deep
underneath a japanese park and it won't
be dug up for five thousand years well
actually um there were two uh one above
the other and the the upper clock will
be
removed
dug up and then reburied after
inspection every hundred
i love years japanese style i really
like that you know you know the there's
an underground aspect of big ben
uh brian nino and i went to big bend you
know early in all this
and um you have a choice of going up the
elevator or going up the you know very
well known number of very many stairs to
the top
and uh we of course went up the stairs
grind grind grind all the way up and
then very much like our 10 000 o'clock
in texas
uh you're in the dark until you're
suddenly in the light and with a big
view in the long view
and there you have the uh you know being
right next to big ben himself the
biggest bell
and uh we were told that um
uh
when it rings be careful there's nothing
that you you might uh strike when your
head flies back from the sound and if
you hit something you'll be sorry
uh we were both surprised that actually
with that warning
when the bell
was smitten just a few feet away from us
it was a huge and wonderful sound but
not painful
and so it was a very bodily experience
uh
to enjoy big ben that way i recommend it
to anybody and i hope our clock will
have his exquisite feeling to it
so um
yeah i have a question um
in the coming decades and beyond we are
likely to spend more
time off of our planet
and i'm wondering about time keeping in
space and
maybe even the moon
whether you've
researched
what
is happening there and and whether you
have a recommendation
about
keeping time in space or other planets
um
if you kind of imagine starting anew so
okay we're gonna go to the moon and show
what would be a good way to do time
keeping on the moon
that's a really great question and um do
you have an easier one
i mean this is some it's not something
that i've given um thought to
although um one of the organizations i'm
involved with um the
from the 17th century the worshipful
company of clockmakers the the kind of
the london guild of talkmakers um
was involved in a competition for people
thinking about i think it was a martian
clock
and to think through this this is for
teenagers kind of design and engineering
um to think through what
what do you need to think about when
thinking about time off a planet
whether that's everything to do with the
fact we've got our hard-wired circadian
rhythms
you know would wouldn't they need a
change would we need to evolve
um how long would that take
what are the what are the natural cycles
of the place where we now are
i guess my only comment would be to
think about um
like a
[Music]
timeless place on earth
um or or a place where time is very
differently experienced which is the
poles um and so for instance antarctica
um where the concept of earth rotation
time just just it just doesn't apply in
the same way
and so what time systems if time systems
are useful as we discussed earlier in
not just knowing the time but in making
other things work at what time do they
use um i think the answer was
um variably either you know greenwich
time utc or new zealand time if it's the
closest place but i think the question
that you ask kevin is is a really
profound one
because it forces us to think through
all of the ways in which time plays a
role in our lives as as as human animals
and also in our societies in faith um in
um in civilizations but also in kind of
technological development would the
clocks enable them to happen
well i want to thank stuart and kevin
for joining us
we're going to go on and take a few more
questions from
from our audience um and as we as we do
that um
david you mentioned you know the the
polls which i always find just this you
know this thing where the all the time
zones come together in this one point
right like it's the place where you can
walk around every time zone and as you
look at the way the time zones are drawn
across the globe they tend to be drawn
you know there's this notion of a of a
perfect pie wedge but you watch the
politics of it move and you mention this
a bit in your talk but um i wonder if
you you know
this and this also gets us to a subject
that i know everyone is going to want to
know your your take on daylight savings
time but um
what's your take on this on the way that
um that the politicization of time zones
and how that works in certain countries
where there are no time zones versus
places that just don't have enough power
to push the time zone
out of their way
i mean time standardization absolutely
fascinates me of um
in so many different ways and the way i
say it is um
that time is inherently political or
rather the use of time in societies is
inherently political and so that so i
don't see it as
something kind of scientific which then
got politicized it was always political
it could never be anything other
so the idea in 1884 at that conference
in washington dc which came up with the
idea of a single prime meridian for the
world which led to i mean it was
complicated what was just discussed at
that meeting and subsequently but it led
to the idea of
uniform 24-hour 24 different time zones
each an hour wide all indexed back to a
fixed line a fixed meridian a fixed
north south line and that one was chosen
to be greenwich
and of course as you say you just look
at any time zone chart from 1884 to the
present day and there's not a straight
line
in sight um
even the international date line the 180
degrees line which passes mostly through
the pacific ocean is the most
astonishing the acrobatic line because
of course there are plenty of of um
people and lands in that area
so
so standardization of time across
territories is highly political
the time that you keep on your clock
is
in other words your time zone broadly
defined
is an expression can be an expression of
allegiance it can be an expression of
national identity it can be an
expression of resistance some examples
um being
china which is about
five hours of time wide but it has one
time zone which is beijing time and
that's quite far to the east
that was one of the first acts of mao
zedong
in 1949
was to unify china's time to one time
zone and to make that beijing time
and for that to then get rooted in the
psyche of chinese people that beijing
time represents
um
the chinese identity the chinese people
that it became patriotic to see time in
china as beijing time
and then there have been times when time
zones have been changed to make a
political statement um venezuela hugo
chavez in nothing 2007 changed the time
by half an hour that was reversed a few
years later
north korea more recently 2015 changed
the time by half an hour
time zones are
some of my favorite
i love the hotel time zones and um
and i talked in the film about about
india which is five and a half hours um
and how that was you know that was just
a deeply deeply political set of acts in
the 19th and early 20th century
um
because the point is of course that the
time kept on clocks isn't
the right time whatever that turns out
to mean um it's been an increasing
fiction
since we moved from
um a sundial-based
um system to a an equal hours-based
system
not just when mechanical clocks were
invented it was long before that right
but we decided we wanted equal hours
rather than seasonal hours um so that
was one shift then of course
standardization in the 19th and 20th
centuries and then daylight saving which
moves us an hour
um
ahead and then and then the final
fiction which is really interesting is
the leap second which tethers our time
right now to earth rotation time even
though it's kept by atomic clocks and if
the lip second is abolished we cut ties
with the rotation of the earth
right and that the time lords are in
constant argument we've touched base
with them a few times on this subject
and it's they both sides have kind of
asked us to kind of choose their side of
keeping it bound to earth's rotation or
not which i think is funny
and also that that you know the time
zone for uh that's closest to where
we're installing the clock is actually
runs just a few hundred meters uh
by the clock site itself because it was
historically a place so very low
political power um but it's you know it
was almost the case that we our clock
face could have been split by the by the
time zone which i thought would have
been
especially hilarious to have one side of
the clock face and one time zone and
another one in the other uh i'm gonna
let you go i know it's starting to get
laid out there but i wanted to get you
know one last question from you um you
know
what are you what what are you gonna do
next with your time what's up what's
your next project that's a really good
question i mean i'm i've
this this the work on this book has
given me so many things to think about
i i don't see it i'm sorry for anyone
who's bought the book but i don't see it
as a finished work it's it's it's raised
far more questions in me than it's
answered but it's given me some um
directions to go and certainly one of
those directions is to think about that
modern period that we talked about um
earlier with stu and kevin about the
kind of the embeddedness
and the pervasiveness of very accurate
time in our lives and how things run on
clocks um in in ways which we've kind of
not noticed and it's increasing the
power that those clocks have i'm kind of
interested in kind of exploring that a
little bit further to see just what
clocks do for us now
indeed and i think you know what some of
the other questions that did come up
i'll just close with is you know about
time stamps themselves and and now we're
seeing cryptographic blockchains
effectively these are clocks with kind
of you know an irregular tick of a time
stamp but they're now driving whole
economies and and so i think it's going
to be really interesting the way that
plays out and look forward to talking
with you about it hopefully at some
point in the future most definitely
take care
and thank you all for joining us with
the talk and we'll see you in the future
thank you
[Music]
you